there's a scene in the movie Flashdance
where some people are taught rocking
bustin out back spins freezes and a move
that would later be called a moonwalk
but they aren't just some random kid
they're members of the Rock Steady Crew
one of the most influential crews have
brought Hollywood Fame to breaking many
people recognize the term breakdancing
I mean coined by the media in the 80s
but to Feyen ears and practitioners of
the dance form call it b-boying or
breaking the name breaking is broadly
believed to have come from DJ Kool Herc
in the Bronx in New York City when
hosting block parties in the 70s he
started isolating the beat create break
in the song it just refers to a moment
in the song where you build tension by
having me the instruments drop out and
just having percussion or percussion
debates basically the rhythm section
scholar named Barbara browning had to
add a great way to describe it where she
says you feel impelled to fill the
silence with motion the break is a part
of a lot of african-american and
afro-caribbean music especially Latino
music which is a big part of the roots
of this band Porto Rican and Cuban music
in particular
[Music]
traditionally b-boys and b-girls dance
to a mix of funk jazz techno rock and
disco the sound of the music is very
aggressive and very percussive it's a
battle dance so the music gets people in
the mood to battle you want to be able
to really rock the beat you want to be
able to play with those rhythms and
reflect them in your body breaking is
made up of four elements top rock down
Rock power moves and freezes top rock is
the foot movement from a standing
position it's the first display of style
in a warm-up for the acrobatics of down
rock down rockers when breakers use
their hands and feet on the floor this
is where they show off foot speed and
control of their footwork from there a
b-boy can transition into power moves
like the windmill and head spins
these ones meet momentum and a ton of
physical power and the last element is a
freeze where the girl stops dancing and
holds a position that requires
incredible balance these elements often
draw movements from disciplines like
kungfu tap dance gymnastics and capoeira
but there's more to it when breaking
first began it was a way for
disadvantaged kids in the broad to be
recognized it helped transform their
street culture where gang violence
slowly made way for neighborhood crews
that you've danced to compete against
each other
now with those competitions being
commercialized breaking something's
different for the newer generation of
b-boys and b-girls competitions were
breaking for me as a huge asset I
started competing because the energy of
a battle is like amazing and plus it was
money to win you know I wanted to
provide so much my mom my family and
help them out you know it's like a way
for me to just prove myself and be put
myself out there and and get better I
feel like I get better at competition
but there are those who believe that
mainstream breaking has left some
traditions behind a lot of people don't
have that original style no more no
original b-boys will go to parties more
they would do more party rocking and
they would interact more like on a
personal level with the crowd with the
fly girls the b-boys today they just go
to competition they don't necessarily
dance in parties people are attracted to
the acrobatic aspect of it people are
attracted to the flamboyant aspect of it
but bottom line is it's a dance and and
all that the gymnastics and the
acrobatics are all flavoring to add on
top of the core which is really dancing
which is rhythm and movement and
self-expression breaking in its original
form is more than just the dance it's
the connection to your family and your
friends your neighborhood rivals your
community and hip-hop cultures very
important to be connected to the
community because we come from these
communities and we can't even attempt to
give back in some type of way culturally
financially economically spiritually
philosophically I feel we fall short a
lot of hip-hop dance and hip hop in
general is about getting people to
notice you and I think that the personal
thing for each individual person but
it's also a political statement all of
that stuff is embedded in the dance just
to say not only am i important as an
individual but my community is important
and the concerns of my community are
important and the perspective the point
of view of my community is important
[Music]